good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning
I'm really struggling welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday hope everyone's
having a fabulous day this Friday Jax
are you having a fabulous day this far
our day could not be more fabulous thus
far we're recording a little later today
because this morning we had a very
special occasion we were celebrating a
simcha the bris of our nephew and they
are simcas they are happy occasions but
they're really like kind of emotional
and tough because the Biba is crying and
crying and crying and you really can't
do anything about it no and I know you
guys weren't there but let me just
replay it for you
pretty much that's how it went that's
why Jackie and I are watching on YouTube
which you should be we look so
unbelievably gorgeous and sickening
we're both wearing dresses and we have
our hair done and our makeup done and
we've got our big heels on our big heels
so it's freezing in this studio and I'm
gonna cover up with a blanket but I just
wanted everyone to see the fabulousness
that is Jackson Claude on this gorgeous
Tuesday morning right and we were
thinking about changing for the show but
it's like why do we have to be slobs if
we're wearing fabulous outfits like why
can't we wear the fabulous episode in
the show well we can do whatever we want
but I do feel like I am my funniest when
I feel like a slob do you know what I
mean yeah so it'll be interesting to see
how today's it's probably gonna be our
least funny episode today it goes in
shapewear 100 I'm actually not wearing
any shape where I didn't bring any isn't
that crazy that is crazy I can't breathe
I'm so sorry
um we've got a Fab show we've got a Fab
show we've got Fast Five no TV recap
tonight today and today's episode is up
a little bit later but like we were
celebrating the gift of life so everyone
can wait a minute you know yes they can
no TV recap but I did finish my program
the empress not the program it was so
good I have to read a book about CC now
like I can't wait till season two to
know Cece's fate even though I do know a
little bit
um once I finish the book that I am
currently embroiled in then I have to
read the book for the redheads and then
I'll be reading about CeCe I think the
accidental Empress by Allison Pataki so
there is no TV recap
um but I did start watching the new
season of Love is Blind and I'm not
going to finish it because it's really
just not my favorite show like it's just
not however there was a moment that I
want to tell you about that like you
will find so funny I mean I sat in for
two seconds and I it made me actually
want to watch this season well I really
am enjoying it because one of the the
girls who gets engaged and who
um is I think becoming a fan favorite is
a plus-sized girl and they never include
plus size people and like that's a real
factor in dating blind like so I really
appreciate it and like I think she has
like the best guy and um she's Israeli
too which I would just love but do they
meet yeah yeah and he's all about it
he's like oh my God you're so beautiful
like Oh yay I told you he was gonna
think so that's the scene that I saw
yeah and Claudia was like saying I don't
know if he knows right like it's I do
feel like it's something you share like
if you
I don't I don't know I feel like they
don't show us this but I do feel like
you describe a little bit what you look
like over the hours of talking to
someone like I think I would say I have
red hair right it's the same kind of
thing right well that's not the moment
though I wanted to tell you about there
was this like cringe moment where I was
so confused and I was curious if anyone
else is this one girl I think her name
is Raven
um she's like I have to tell you
something and everyone has like
something like like a like a burden or
something they want to share like one
girl was like you know I was an egg
donor for a different family so like
there's potentially over a hundred of my
biological children a lot of guys aren't
into that the guy was like that's fine
with me so everyone has like a thing so
this girl was like being really dramatic
about her thing and she goes
um so yeah I work in the service
industry on the weekends and the guy was
like so like you strip
I thought she was saying she's a
prostitute
and she was like no like I bartend and
stuff and he was like okay
and she was like
yeah and just like a lot of guys like I
have really not been happy with that it
was so dramatic like for what for what I
was like what am I missing I'm like is
this a weird way of saying like
I like I'm a prostitute like I was it
was such a weird moment that is weird
and she was like no that's Tripper and
it's like well that's what you sounded
like yeah she bartends on the weekends
like millions of people it was the
weirdest thing that is really weird
um I'm not gonna finish it just because
like it's a lot of episodes and there's
really only one couple that like I'm
actually interested in but um people
seem to really be enjoying the season
more so than they've enjoyed previous
Seasons that's great I'll get a button
on my dress already fell off oh good
thing you had that extra sack of buttons
that you pulled off before like why is
everything in my life broken and the
stress is brand new I don't know but it
looks great on you thank you so much
it's so beautiful thank you anti-sac
Michaela's really Gotten Good at saying
our names obviously Jackie's most
because you live here and she said
Auntie sack and for me education
it is like hearing my name come from the
Lips of an Angel like there's really no
sound more beautiful except for my own
voice but of course pretty good of
course
um was there anything else you wanted to
chat about before we dived in like um we
have good stories today we do have good
stories book update I'm reading the
princess spy which is that history book
by the man that I was talking about and
it's so what happened was last week I
read historical fiction about Hedy
Lamarr and I came to find out afterwards
that like
the artist the author took some artistic
Liberties left out some stuff and I'm
like well that's annoying I want to know
the true story like maybe historical
fiction like I need to be reading more
history because they really
improv too much and I want to know I
know I'm this is riveting so trying to
keep your eyes
closed over
no tote no totally yeah like so rude so
it's it's so rude it's so rude it's I
don't complain about a lot but like it's
so rude of me and it's not even like
pretend to be interesting just be
interested in what your sister's saying
it's so rude of me but also like it's
hella boring like it's really not not
for the readers out there okay
oh arrived in silence thank you
okay so we're moving on yeah no
finishing a story I want to move on okay
so we have a Fast Five today some really
sad news I'm assuming it's a story
Leslie Jordan yeah so sad so we'll talk
about that
um and we'll just talk about things most
ourselves and mostly the the kids yeah
are you gonna do that the whole time
okay well I guess I could then kind of
like do a one-woman show if you're just
gonna be moving me the whole time
finish the thing about your breakfast
come on no no you don't get to hear it
and everyone's gonna just be on the edge
of their seats all day okay just
wondering maybe you'll like I chose this
book maybe you'll put some like extra
um like info and details on your
Instagram that's a good way we can drive
people to your Instagram
oh now she's trying to butter me up and
I'm trying to help yeah you're clearly
mad like you're clearly pressed
meanwhile I didn't even say anything
until you called me out I was just being
like agreeable agreeable
[Laughter]
so so you're not sharing
like there's a whole thing and you're
not gonna share I'll share it for
everyone else yeah don't do it for me I
don't even care if you're listening or
not you can leave the room for all I
care
um no so then I was like I want to read
the history about someone not someone's
interpretation please stop saying just
stop
and so this book is straight facts as
Lionel States I think that's his name in
the
beginning of the book
sorry like that's how I talk like that's
how I Converse like if you don't like it
if you don't like it like that's on you
that's how I talk okay okay you're not
gonna silence me now and I'm finding it
to be a little dry where is the ad
living he even said at one point like
every conversation that happens in the
book is directly taken from a
correspondence there's no fiction here
and now I understand why they add a
little fiction to these things because
it's a little dry but I'm gonna trust
the process and I'm gonna finish the
book TTP man just the process and if
anyone's read it and liked it please
continue encourage me because I'm 18 so
that seems like a waste for sure to back
off now 100 100 thank you for for
sharing and I'm sorry that my feigned
interest wasn't enough for you but like
I can only like fake it so much until
you know my I guess my issue is like I
never have to fake it for you well maybe
it's because I talk about interesting
things no that's not it no but like
but like what do you what do I talk
about that like you truly like don't
care she's like no it's not that I I
listen like the thing is I never don't
care about what you're saying okay so
what you're saying is you're better than
me okay can we move on sure
um also Jackie and I made a tick tock
today and I just feel like we're kind of
like breaking the internet we're just
like showing off our outfits being cute
making the briss about us and if you
want to check that out like you
definitely should oh also we didn't
really even talk about you know
privately let alone publicly kind of how
you know me a childless woman kind of
became like the face of motherhood
yesterday you really did yeah honestly I
was really glad that the episode
resonated with so many moms and like we
got tagged in so many stories people
being like truly thank you like I was
listening to this while breastfeeding so
I just I wanted to reiterate that point
like stay-at-home moms we see you yeah
and I know that we have so many
listeners who are stay-at-home moms and
I figured they'd be appreciate being
seen yesterday but I was really moved by
how moved everyone was that we just took
a moment to appreciate our SAS HMS out
there also a moment to appreciate the
working moms because that's [ __ ] hard
too like being a full-time working mom
and then also have to you know be a
parent morning and night and then like
leaving your child which is also really
hard yes definitely yeah especially for
moms in general I just was reading an
interesting article about like the the
new roles of like men and women
especially as pertaining to the family
and how even women who work like instead
of being stay-at-home moms like wound up
picking up a double shift because so you
still have to cook right well and take
care of it both and so it's like kind of
a raw deal no that's what I've kind of
learned as I've grown up and like
everyone around me is having children
like being a mom Raw Deal
like of course the gift of life is such
a blessing and we should all be so lucky
but like normalized talking about the
bad parts of it too yeah no The Gift of
Life is the greatest gift really and
that's why you put up with everything
else that's what makes it worth it yes
and that's what makes you beautiful oh
so this funny ass video of Ellen
DeGeneres at the um Harry Styles he's
you know how he did an MSG residency he
started one in L.A Marie was there yeah
Jason Marie was there
um and Ellen was there you know with her
you know fancy seats and somebody was
videoing her listening to that so it
makes you beautiful and like it was one
of those videos where like you're
watching someone pretend to know the
words like and it was of the hook it was
that's what makes you and she was like
watermelon yeah yeah it was like so
cringe I personally feel extremely
uncomfortable watching people pretend to
know the lyrics to songs like either
just like don't sing or know the words
don't sing it's totally fine it's so
embarrassing and if I'm ever caught like
on video or just like in real life like
flubbing the words I get so embarrassed
because I'm like would people know us as
the girls who like know the lyrics We
retained so many lyrics so if I'm ever
like caught not knowing I feel like
hella embarrassed or like when someone's
like videoing in the club and then it
goes to you and like you don't you don't
know that part
yeah that actually just take yourself
home that actually happened to me with
Shannon Ford um we were at a birthday
party and my song started to play
because it was my friend's birthday
party and he put on a playlist which was
really nice and I'm filming Margot and
me and then I go to Shannon and like it
wasn't like the the chorus and like
Shannon didn't know the words which was
like deeply offensive but I did restart
the video at the chorus and then she
knew the words that's something that's
all you got to do because I'm a good
friend you are I mean I sure it was
about her I did it for her yeah of
course of course as you do all things
for others for others so I feel like we
can dive in
um
to the top five yeah without further uh
didn't do where are you
Theo loves his auntie
where is Brew The Strife Brothers Love a
British
where is Brew probably with his auntie
cause he spends more time with me and
Theo than he does with you it's while
I'm here while Claudia's here Bruno
comes always be found in her room that's
where he chooses to spend his time I am
I'm so happy for him like me too that's
what I promised him when I told him you
guys were coming I said Bruno's
Adventure like go do your thing I'm
laying in bed last night and like feel
mindlessly like gets in bed and like
lays in my lap I don't even like look at
him and then 20 minutes later I'm
scrolling Tick Tock you come in you're
like Bruno and I look at my lap and it's
Bruno in my lap I just assumed it was
Theo yeah no it says on the floor in the
luggage
Bruno's obsessed Bruno's obsessed but
he's also obsessed with besting Theo
yeah like becoming auntie's number one
just to spite Theo yeah like Theo can't
have anything that Bruno like if I give
Theo a scratch Bruno shows up his tail
yeah hey what about me where's my
scratch belly time yeah because I
explained it to you like Bruno was
taking a backseat to Harry obviously
like he knows I'm not the number two boy
in this group because things change but
he won't sink any further than number
two he must be number two now and Theo
cannot come anywhere near that number I
respect that's all I do I do but he's
like not that way with Magnolia it's so
funny like he literally comes for Theo's
jugular chivalry with Magnolia she's a
lady yes he was just like bro calm down
right we are all friends no bro except
trying so hard that's really what it is
so here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your toast how's that
Croatia
foreign
well today's just episode is brought to
you by catch do you want beautiful hair
with minimal effort kids feels the same
way they upgraded familiar products into
game-changing Essentials that beauty
enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time-saving towels
kitchener's hair care doesn't stop in
the shower so kit is the hair brand that
you just need like period end of story
I've had products from Kitsch before
they became a sponsored then I got a ton
of stuff when they became a sponsor and
didn't even realize like the hair stuff
that I Loved Before was from Kitsch like
the clock Clips are some of my favorite
um whatever your budget is whatever your
skin type or hair type is kids believes
that you deserve indulgences at
affordable prices and that's morning
noon and night so it started in 2010 now
they're female founded brand that were
carried in over 20 000 retail locations
and here are their best sellers satin
pillowcases caps and eye masks so if you
wake up with like ratty hair and like
wrinkles on your face it's because
um your pillowcases are like leaving
indentations in your hair and on your
face and I'm a really rough sleeper and
so when I got a satin pillowcase it
changed my hair like I didn't have to
give myself a full blowout and re-curl
every strand of my hair when I woke up
in the morning
the satin is made of vegan materials
it's cruelty free
um and it's so good for your hair and
the eye masks are so good for your skin
while you sleep they also make shampoo
and conditioner bars so it's bottle free
Beauty they're bars it's really
sickening it's actually like really fun
to do
um they also have the heatless satin
curling rollers that I saw everyone
using on Tick Tock so I bought before
they became a sponsor
um you if you're like really conscious
of not damaging your hair with heat
which I think a lot of us are especially
the older we get
um the heatless curlers from kit are
fabulous they also have the quick dry
hair towel so if you retain a lot of
water in your hair like some of us take
showers at noon and by noon the next day
our hair is still wet you can use one of
their quick dry towels it works like a
dream you won't even realize
um how quickly your hair is drying it's
fabulous and of course they're classic
hair ties and scrunchies which are all
super premium I was using one yesterday
so kitch is offering you 30 off your
entire order at mykitch.com toast that's
right 30 off anything and everything at
my kitchen which is
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast
mykitch.com toast for 30 off your order
thank you mclartia you're welcome first
story Adidas drops Kanye West after
anti-semitic comments Adidas officially
has ended its partnership with Kanye
after he made numerous anti-semitic
comments they released a statement today
saying quote Adidas does not tolerate
anti-Semitism and any other sort of hate
speech EA's recent comments and actions
have been unacceptable hateful and
dangerous and they violate the company's
values of diversity and inclusion mutual
respect and fairness took them a long
time to do it yeah I think it's been two
weeks and I saw uh you know like yearly
revenue for Adidas when it comes to
Kanye is almost 300 million dollars so
this wasn't like a a small decision they
had to make right it did take them quite
quite a long time
um and this now has Kanye officially
removed from the Forbes billionaires
list because that deal is worth so much
money to him got it
I have so many different thoughts and
feelings of this whole thing
on the one hand like not even on the
money I don't know if I'm the only
person who like didn't care whether
Adidas drops him or not like it doesn't
change anything and it makes me feel
even like now experiencing it and
watching this all play out like makes me
feel even more sure like canceling
people doesn't help anything doesn't
solve anything it's not any better for
the Jewish people that Kanye doesn't
have a deal with Adidas like I I don't
care especially when it's like two weeks
later I saw like people saying they've
dropped athletes sooner for using
steroids right
okay let's talk about his uh talent
agency CAA after two weeks dropped him
your girl got canceled in 2018 for
tweets I wrote in high school and I was
canceled that morning like it was less
than an hour so everyone that makes it
feel like so performative I think though
for a lot of people like Jewish like Ben
and his friends they love Adidas like I
don't think a lot of people is from the
Jewish Community like are going to be
really comfortable and down to be like
spending a lot of money on Adidas
sneakers like knowing that like this is
not something they like immediately want
to stay away from like if you like if
someone if one of our TNN shows was
saying crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] like you don't
want to be associated with that it's
more it's not canceling but it's more
like ew like go away and also like we
live in a cancel culture right like
these are the consequences right so it's
odd that it took them so long for anyone
else saying anything else it would have
been much more Swift or doing anything
else as it's been in the past it's not
like Adidas like doesn't subscribe to
the same corporate law that everyone
else does and a lot of people are like
well you know as someone who doesn't
believe in cold cancel culture like how
do you reconcile this is it only because
you're Jewish and I think that's a good
question this makes me believe in cancer
culture even less because I'm watching
this and I'm like this changes nothing
this fixes nothing this only has Kanye
digging his heels and deeper this only
proves what he's saying to his fans is
true because it seems like the Jews
control everything right this solves
nothing I think and for the people who
are like yes finally Adidas shop him
it's like the smallest of potatoes and
you're missing the whole big picture the
whole point but I just to to finish my
point is like I feel like cancel culture
went like went to a place where it's
like if you had you know old tweets from
your past come back like everything you
had worked for gets taken from you if
you said something that you didn't mean
to be offensive but obviously it came
out offensive or it offended people like
intent versus impact you'll immediately
lose everything okay sir right so it's
like for me I feel like those three
types of scenarios leave no room for
Grace like no room for people maybe just
like genuinely making a mistake in the
case of Connie no mistakes were made it
hasn't even doubled down quadrupled down
he did the Pierce Morgan interview like
it's clear that this is how he feels
it's not like an incident where somebody
made a mistake and an incidence where
people have made mistakes or things from
their past come up were so quick to act
like we can't we can't strip them of
their accomplishments fast to put fast
enough like we can't do enough and so
for Kanye it's been like yeah this is
how I feel
I'm not taking it back I'm actually
going to go even further all of that and
that takes two weeks that's why cancel
culture is flawed because can't this is
not cancel culture cancel culture is
stripping someone of all of that their
right to make a living all of their
accomplishments for a mistake that they
made right and that they're and that's
very easily apologizing for and really
eager and open to understand why it was
right and move on and just not accepting
people's oppositions this is not that no
this is just straight up anti-Semitism
yeah and I do I know we have like kind
of differing opinions on this like I do
and I hear what you're saying for me
like blogging onto social media and
seeing like finally like everyone is
talking about anti-Semitism I am
grateful and and I they're not talking
about anti-Semitism they're talking
about communities and I just like this
is a in an ideal world for me this would
be a gateway to learning about
everything else but I just think like
the obsession with Kanye it's like it's
kind of missing the point no and like I
understand why you feel like logging on
and seeing everyone's posting like I
support Jews Jewish because it feels
like forever like literally we were like
that was never gonna happen yeah yeah
and that nobody and nobody cared until
yes it's nice to see that people care
but like in the
picture the whole picture of
anti-Semitism like it's not a small
potatoes this is and it's everyone
agrees like Kanye is wrong and nuts and
yeah so I don't feel like it does
anything and to me like it the worst
part is that people have now feel like
they've helped oh I posted that I did my
part anti-Semitism is solved right let's
move on when things are worse than
they've ever been so I guess and what's
what is alarming for me it's not just
like what Kanye is saying but I don't
think he's really converting anyone to
being anti-semitic I think it's they're
coming out of the woodwork it's
highlighting how many people are
anti-semitic that's very true when you
look at the comments on anyone who
posted any celebrity who posted I said
that black thing with the blue font I
support my Jewish friends
um and look at the comments yeah no
you're right people like getting more
comfortable in their anti-Semitism
that's that's so true so I guess like in
an Ideal World this would be a Gateway
and like anyone who's you know wanting
to do more and not just be like oh I
fixed Kanye I'm done
I guess we would implore you to like
keep looking because this is nothing
compared to what goes on every day and
every single day in Jewish community and
it's so bizarre to me not by and not
bizarre but it's like interesting to me
what gets circulated you know every
single day I follow accounts like stop
anti-Semitism the Israel files stand
with us every single day in my news feed
I see instances of anti-Semitism in this
country campuses violence graffiti Jews
will die every single type people on the
highway honk if the Jews made covet
whatever and just this time it's that
one picture that everybody's sharing of
the song If Kanye was right the highway
thing and it's like there are so many
things like this that nobody cares about
yes why now why this picture I agree I
honestly like I just think you need to
lower your standards like
people are talking about it and like we
can nitpick and stuff but like it's just
this cycle of like if something get get
sparks outrage everybody posts the same
thing they feel like they've marked
themselves as safe because I showed my
support and it's like that's just not
support no there's a there's a myriad of
issues when it comes to like social
media actions
every few months there's something else
that comes a different cause you know
you didn't help and the worst part is
that like you actually think that you
didn't so you're not going to do
anything to actually okay so
what can people do to help to
anti-Semitism support Israel yeah the
board Israel and anyone who tells you
Israel's engaging in ethnic cleansing or
genocide or any of that nonsense call
them out that is a lie and don't just
take my word for it like go read the
history it's in the Bible like it's
history study up on it learn about
Jewish history learn about why Zionism
is not a dirty word and why it's so
important for the Jewish people to have
a home state that to me that's how you
can help and that means everything to me
educate yourself on the Holocaust one in
two people don't know what the Holocaust
is yeah that's it yeah that's good and
don't like stand for people in their
lives I think this is a great start
how's that I just don't think it's the
start I think it's the end I'm choosing
to be a hopeful girly a positive girly
and so
yeah I don't know why like con at Adidas
shopping like doesn't right right
especially after so many weeks it's like
oh you're really only doing it because
you probably not it would not because
you actually cared you hoped it would
blow over and that you could get away
with it and fly under the radar Hunter
so that's the latest with yay
more like nay
next story Leslie Jordan has died at the
age of 67. Leslie Jordan died on Monday
morning after a car crash his rep
confirmed to page six the famed comedian
was driving in Hollywood when it was
later suspected he suffered some sort of
medical emergency and crashed his BMW
into the side of the building the
American Horror Story star was also
known for his work in Will and Grace
hearts of fire call me cat and of course
his viral Instagram content during the
pandemic that brought a lot of joy to a
lot of people oh my God this is so sad
you know when like it reminded me when
you hear of like a celebrity dying and
it's kind of sudden like you're you're
just like for a moment like you
it's like an existential crisis like I
remember I felt that when I heard that
Kobe Bryant had died because Leslie
Jordan was only 67 and he's just like a
very present figure on social media and
it's just like I'm I'm shocked yeah and
I was so confused as to how he died I
assumed it was like a you know a medical
thing and then it was a car crash and a
medical thing so I'm just this is really
sad like honestly P John like real true
pajam true pjam I hopefully will get
more details in the following days of
what exactly happened there's pictures
of the car crashing into like the side
of a building so I think the speculation
that he had a medical emergency or
something yeah is probably correct yes
so sad
so so shocked when I read this like I
was like wait like the like the
the words weren't generating like
Computing in my brain do you know what I
mean yeah like I have that sometimes
like when something I just get like
crazy news like the words aren't making
sense in English yeah you know no I I do
it's really sad and I feel like a lot of
people like we're really big fans of him
so
rest in peace rest in peace
our next Story Taylor Swift drop some
content for the swifties she transformed
into Cinderella for sparkling Bejeweled
video she said this video is wild
Whimsical and created specifically for
you my beloved fans who have paved this
shimmering path
let's talk about the video it was really
important because Taylor it was like a
plan Cinderella she had three evil
stepsisters played by the hame sisters
an evil stepmother played by Laura Dern
who was excellent how you doing
um and Taylor played the Wench which was
really like thrilling it was big for
wenches everywhere it was big for the
Wench Community the when she we are firm
leaders in
so I was so like they said the word
wench like two or three times in the
video and I was just like living for it
because when she's become one of my
favorite words they said another word
that we love weasel yes and they said
another word that we love I was just
thinking it
she said lest we forget yeah so it was
like kind of like a toasty music video
quite toasty um and the premise of the
video is that there's like this ball and
you know there's a talent competition
and the person who wins the talent
competition gets a proposal from The
Prince and a key to a castle obviously
Taylor you know sneaks out of the house
goes to the talent competition wins and
denies the proposal but takes the castle
Queen
um it was star-studded
um deed of antiques was in it Pat
McGrath was in it Jack Antonoff Laura
Dern and the hame sisters but for me
what I really took away from the music
video was like I think this is the first
time ever that I've seen Taylor be like
sexy in a bikini she's like always been
very conservative and she talks about
that a lot in her
documentary and it's not for the reasons
one might think it's just like it's just
not something she's ever really been
comfortable doing a bikini the
burlesque show she's wearing a diamond
bikini it's not like high-waisted stuff
no she's wearing many different outfits
but one of them is a bra and undies but
like they're badass oh I see I see yeah
yeah so it was just like kind of crazy
like now that I think about it I've seen
her in a bikini once in these blurry um
pictures when she was staying in Lenny
Kravitz's RV remember on the beach her
and Joe well because people think she
doesn't have a belly button but her
belly button is seen here she looks
amazing
um I just felt like it was so crazy like
she's just not that girl yeah like I
loved it she looked incredible and like
the aesthetic of the video which was
like very 50s glamor
um burlesque Bejeweled big martini
glasses did avantese side Parts it was
amazing and I loved it I was just like
really Shook at like the body I mean her
body's incredible but like we've never
seen it yeah that's just not what Taylor
does because she's like this she's
always been like this conservative girly
like red arrow wearing like Keds and
below the knee skirts for sure and yes
this is probably the most skin we've
seen from her but it's still like a
fashion bikini like they're it's more
covered than like uh it's still such
triangle bathing suit yeah but it's
still it's a sexy shirt it's a sexy baby
she looks so good like really it was a
really beautiful music video and of
course there's like so many Easter eggs
I think a lot of people for for them
this video pretty much confirmed that
the next recording is speak now because
someone said don't speak it like Laura
Dern said in the beginning Laura Dern
said something in the beginning in the
beginning before the music video starts
they're actually playing Enchanted in
the background
um when she gets in the elevator she
goes to the third floor Oh I thought it
was because of 13. no but there are 13
floors in the building of course
um then she's wearing clips in her hair
that say TS and then then again it says
um SN
so I don't think she was really trying
to be coy like I think she's like being
like yeah speak now is next which is
super exciting obviously I was hoping
for 1989 but like it's okay
um and I have to imagine that the
version of Enchanted that was at the
beginning which was very low and
difficult to hear is Taylor's version
right yeah if she's sampling it right
she's like an immersion she's gonna pay
scooter no so it was just a really
stunning music video she went on Jimmy
Fallon last night to like tease it and
get everyone excited and she looked
great she's just like this is a really
like stunning era for her she looks so
good and tall and happy and healthy and
I'm just loving it really truly loving
it yeah the Aesthetics are great and the
music videos have been really premium I
really like the anti-hero one that one
wasn't as like glamorous it was very
like introspective like because the
whole concept of the album is like
things that keep you up at night and I
think for a lot of people like everyone
has like these insecurities about the
way other people perceive them and so
she had these three different versions
of herself that she feels like other
people see her as and I guess I never
really put together like she's a really
tall girl and I guess tall girls are
like insecure about their height tall
girl right unless you're like a model
which most tall girls are not
um so she's like this giant version of
herself and the house that she's in is
like a dollhouse to her because she's so
tall and I think obviously even if
you're not tall you can relate to that
sentiment of like being kept up at Night
by like your appearance and like what
people must see you as yeah that's what
I feel today in these shoes like so tall
ever I'm just like a monster right like
if it was my music video like my late
night version of myself would be like a
big hairy moly Beast because that's like
how petrified I am that everyone sees me
that way do you know what I mean what
would yours be oh well now you have me
thinking about being short like being
short does not bother me in this life it
doesn't but I do think like people I
think it bothers other people like no
about it like they look at us and
they're like we're so [ __ ] them yeah
yeah like I just feel like it really
clouds how people see us but not how I
see myself I just like seriously don't
care like I'd so much rather be short
than tall yeah and that's just I'm being
like small and being short is like a
cute thing about us you know yeah yeah
like I don't think unless you're a guy
but for a girl I really don't think
there's any downsides to being short of
course being a tall girl you're limited
and you're you know dating options
because you always want to date someone
taller than you like short girls like
want to be taller especially girls who
are like five five and I think see think
they could be models well yeah they're
like they lie about their head to be
taller and it's like
who cares no totally height is like not
something in my brain that I factor but
you're right that it is for other people
but maybe it's because everyone is
taller than us like it's never mattered
yeah I'm just like this is how I see the
world literally and I'm fine with it
same and like when I take pictures with
people I'm like I'm the shortest one
like right I'm so tiny and small and
frail I love it yeah
um so the music videos have been
fabulous she did release a teaser like
before oh it was an Amazon Prime that
Thursday Night Football thing of all the
music video like things that she's gonna
be doing and there were Clips in there
that aren't in the anti-hero video and
that aren't in the Bejeweled video so
there's more coming
that's good I wish like it's a lot to
digest in one week like I wish that
these were singles and that we had time
to process and enjoy because it's a lot
so I actually am she's like flipped the
model yeah from her on on herself yeah
yeah but like and it's cool to like be a
flipper there's a conspiracy theory that
this is a Visual Album kind of how like
formation and every song has a video
cool like I just could have used some
time yeah well now I'm curious Tom give
me no compasses give me no signs now
that we've had like a decent amount of
time I've definitely made more of I'm
able to see the album not as just like a
medley of songs and lyrics but
differentiating one from another and
there are many songs that I'm really
really into
um I think currently you're on your own
kid is probably my favorite
um again because it's just so deeply
introspective like it's it's so on point
it's funny how like we're all so
different but at night like we're all
kept up by the same things yeah no
matter how big or small like everyone
worries about their family I think when
you get to a certain age you worry about
your parents like you like we're all the
same you know yeah and you also worry
about like how you're coming off to
other people and what you look like yeah
the people in your life like we all
really have the same problems and that's
what I learned from the album so I love
your on your own candle that one's like
a lot about like
how other people see you in like your
body
um I love the Great War and I love
Bejeweled like it's such that's we made
it our Tick Tock spoiler alert it was to
Bejeweled yeah we don't want to ruin it
for you yeah but I think but I've
already told you the song and what's in
it so and you've seen our outfits um so
we should still go to my tech talk and
watch us you should best believe them
still Bejeweled well but you know what
with Taylor's albums I really do feel
like it takes me a long time to like get
to know them completely
um and when they come out they really
make me like it highlights my favorite
albums and I feel like this is I've
always said like my favorite Taylor
album is 1989 and it is but I think my
favorite Taylor album is now Evermore
now that like we've moved on to the next
one Evermore is such
a work of art and I feel like it kind of
stands in the shadow of folklore
yeah like people like cream their pants
over fall on this show not in our world
like because Evermore is better than
folklore it is I think ever more like
might be her best album which is like
kind of crazy to say
I it's so hard because I think it's like
Evermore red
and fearless but only because for me
Fearless like
which is what it meant in my life you
know what it didn't like it's in my past
like if I listen to all the songs I
don't want to listen to all them right
now do they remind you of that time in
your life and at that time my life they
were the best songs I've ever heard
right and like you were young and free
and at camp like yeah they were like the
songs that I needed for that time in my
life no totally
so that's the thing
and I feel like this phase that I'm in
now like is it's ever more you're a
number more face well you are like a few
years younger than her so you're just
like a few years behind trailing and if
like when you're 32 you'll be listening
to midnight maybe love that are you
ready for our next story only if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
seeds it is turns out everything you
think you know about probiotics is
probably wrong like those probiotic
tortilla chips they sounded way too good
to be true well the good news is that
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the real
deal not all probiotics are created
equal so the daily symbiotic from seeds
is a broad spectrum two in one probiotic
and Prebiotic it is a 24 strain broad
spectrum probiotic and Prebiotic that's
formulated for Digestive gut immune and
additional systemic benefits the capsule
and capsule protects against stomach
acid digestion enzymes and bile salts
for viability through digestion so what
does that mean the live probiotics will
actually make it to the end of the small
intestine for delivery into your colon
if you've taken a probiotic before and
you didn't feel a difference it's likely
because the good bacteria wasn't
surviving your AI tract seed is designed
differently and that's why it works it
supports benefits in and Beyond the gut
so seed will support the ease of
bloating healthy regularity ease of
evacuation which means you know like
duties on their way out which is really
like a journey for everyone especially
like almost 30 I'm having a hard time
but it'll also support your gut barrier
your skin Health your heart health and
your micronutrient synthesis
so basically there's like an endless
list of benefits to taking
um The Daily symbiotic and I feel like a
lot of people like dabble and prebiotics
and probiotics and it's like tough to
know what's working and what's a good
brand and seeds is totally a brand that
you can trust
um and the daily symbiotic is a
Prebiotic and a probiotic in one
and they have sustained delivery every
month so each component of their refill
system is designed to protect your ds01
daily symbiotic and be gentler on the
earth so if you want to start a new
healthy habit today visit seed.com toast
and use code toast to resume to redeem
20 off your first month of the seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic that's seed
s-e-eed.com toast and use code toast
seed seed.com toast code toast to redeem
20 off your first month thank you
mclartia yeah well
um
so Katy Perry has suffered
um this is Twisted her injury as her
eyelid got stuck during her performance
at her Vegas residency her fans are
joking that she suffered a glitch one
eye open when I'm sleeping um when I
mechanical failure they said but uh her
fans were quick to joke that the usually
well-oiled machine suffered a quote
glitch on Monday night after her eyelid
appeared to get stuck during her Las
Vegas residency in footage which has
been uploaded to tick tock the singer
could be seen struggling to open one of
her eyes in the middle of the show with
many users quipping she suffered a quote
mechanical failure it was really like
creepy to watch like she has no control
over one of her eyelids and it like
stays shut and she tries to open it and
it shuts it's giving like horror movie
it looks really scary she like maybe
she's like doing too much and going too
bad like she needs to see a doctor and
she needs to like it was actually really
scary like it was like a total loss of a
motor skill yes it was really like like
people shouldn't be joking about it even
myself like it looked I'm not a doctor
obviously but it looked like hella
serious it did look very serious some
people are speculating that she had
eyelash glue
um or was wearing I saw someone say that
there was lash um the magnetic lashes
and so if you put them on the bottom no
then the top one can get stuck to the
bottom one but that's not it no and it
seems to be a medical issue it reminds
me of like kind of what Justin Bieber
when he had yeah like a paralysis of the
face yeah so it's really scary the
videos really creepy like it really it's
one of those things that gives you a
chill up your spine no and like I think
when it first came out people thought it
was photoshopped or felt like a filter
yeah um but I hope she's okay me too
like I feel like I actually kind of want
to see her biggest residency I've heard
it's really good and then she's just
like doing a lot you know I'm sure it's
great is that a symptom of doing a lot I
don't know but like exhaustion like when
I get really tired I do get like eye
twitches it looks nothing like that and
you can't even see my eye twitching it's
just like in my eyebrow and it really
[ __ ] feels weird but maybe this is
like again I'm not a doctor I'm probably
the furthest thing from a doctor
um so this is just my diagnosis which
again means absolutely nothing to anyone
so your diagnosis is doing a lot yeah my
diagnosis take it take a rest you know
take a nap well diagnosis to see a
doctor see a doctor which I'm sure she
is and like she paused to like try and
she was trying to like open her eyes
open really gross I think she's probably
more shook than anyone else yeah no but
like the video was extremely creepy like
yeah it was giving American Horror Story
I'm not trying to be mean I'm just
saying like it it felt really serious
yes it does I'm sure it's serious to her
too so curious Tom give me no compasses
give me no sense
sorry you can't like start singing you
know um
are you ready for our fifth and final
story so quick
ly a couple of them were like breeze
through a couple this is gonna be our
first episode that's under an hour in
probably two months so we speak too soon
because you never know right now I can
tell you about the next book I want to
read oh no
kidding oh my God I thought we were like
I thought we were at the place where we
could joke it but we're not okay no
maybe tomorrow yeah no like you're
entitled to be like sensitive it's fine
thank you yeah of course some things
like by the way and actually this is
totally serious like sometimes some
things just hate you like normally it
wouldn't bother you but whether it's the
day or just like this one particular
issue like hits you sideways like you
you get upset yeah I get that sometimes
it's just like a one particular issue
maybe it's a build up about other times
I spoke okay come down and all the
others I suffered through yeah
okay our fifth and final story a little
really because one thing about me is
like if someone's talking and telling a
story like I can't be silent no you
really can't you know this is the things
to me right yeah no you don't have to
say anything I can't like I cannot I'm
like yeah yeah right right right right
right that's what I do
it's really annoying is this an old
coffee or a new coffee an hour oh you
can have a sip oh no it's not yesterday
it's awesome oh no
so yeah that's just one thing about me
that's why I'm um
and maybe it was like I was a little
bored but maybe like I think if you
remember that it's something that I do
like it comes off like less patronizing
you know it can comfort me during those
directions right right
are you ready for our fifth and final
story a little real estate News Real
Housewives of Orange County Star Javier
Dubrow is selling Chateau Du bro for 55
million dollars Heather Dubrow and her
husband Dr Terry Dubrow have reportedly
sold their 14-bedroom California Mansion
for a staggering 55 million dollars
Heather told Entertainment Tonight with
two kids at College we've been thinking
about our next move we just bought a pen
a cool Penthouse in LA and sometimes the
universe shows you the right direction
change is exciting this was the um now I
think it took the record for the highest
in Orange County the highest residential
home sale wow yeah
I mean it's a sick house it really and
at least we got like one season of it
because she literally left the show as
it was being built and then everyone
used to wonder and she used to like make
people go to her YouTube channel and to
us it feels like she just moved in and
now she's moving out because we only saw
one season but they've been living there
for a really long time and it's really
not that crazy given how long that
they've lived there and they were always
talking about how they would like flip
properties and move on to the next right
because at the end of the day like a
home is an investment no matter how big
or small yeah and their kids like are
grown and you don't need 14 bedrooms no
and like Heather and Terry are like very
much like socialized celebrity thirst
monsters so like they should be in La
they don't need like a big old house an
hour and a half outside la like yeah but
what does this mean for her on the show
like Taylor Armstrong is on and Tamara
returns Taylor Armstrong's I think we
reported that yeah as a friend right
yeah uh
that's a great question so
maybe I don't know maybe she won't come
back I mean they thought it was like
gonna change everything and it changed
quite literally nothing so that's the
thing about things it's like nothing
really changes no that's the thing about
Housewives like at the end of the day
it's an ensemble thing like no matter
even if you have one amazing housewife
that was kind of like Ladies of London
like you had Caroline Stanberry but like
some of the other ladies were falling
flat no no Ladies of London was a
perfect show you know what I mean like
it's not a one-woman show no it's not
it's not so
while Heather coming back was a good
idea like they changed nothing else yeah
therefore nothing changed
therefore yeah
so good for them would love to have just
like 55 Milson in the bank so and
they'll probably go buy some build some
more houses they like had one in Montana
coming up they were like oh yeah Mexico
yeah and I'm sure that they will buy
something else yeah yeah I'm not worried
about them they do not they do well for
themselves yeah I think they'll be just
fine
um so that was the past five that was
our show pretty fast thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast we are
back tomorrow for uh deer toasters
there's no TV on tonight right no tell
me lies is that comes out at midnight
okay so tomorrow or we can watch because
we have oh right yeah oh yeah we could
watch yeah we got screeners because
we're like celebrity but I still have to
watch last week so I'll make time for
that today okay and then tonight it's
Wednesday tomorrow is Salt Lake City and
Beverly Hills okay today's Tuesday I'm
getting so ahead of myself dear toaster
tomorrow a little TV recap and just
another fabulous episode back at regular
timing thank you all so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
this podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so it's Spotify
Tuesday we'll see you tomorrow bye